字幕: Tomoko Hori
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
皆さん １日を振り返った時に
無駄な時間過ごしちゃったって
へこんだりしてませんか
僕は今 看護師として経営者として
その人がどんな人生を生きたいのかを
大事にする仕事をしています
それなのに２年前
非生産的なことを選べず
自分にとって無駄なことは極力避けていました
時間に毎日追われて
周りの人が話しかけにくいぐらい
イライラしてました
頭の中が整理できてない状態が
ストレスだったのと
周りへの申し訳なさもあって
なんとか効率的に
ストレスを発散できないか調べました
結果 僕には運動が必要だと感じたんで
近所にできたジムに通って
効率的な運動をしていました
ある日 歩いている自分が何か無機質で
同じ顔をしたロボットに近づいて行くような
そんな気持ち悪さを感じたんです
そこで 人間らしい僕って何かなって考えたら
木や森 山が
好きだったことを思い出したんです
恥ずかしい話
小さい頃は家出をすることがよくあって
暗くなって寒くなって不安になると
木に抱きついて過ごしてたんです
木って暖ったかくて安心するんですよ
それから僕は
家の裏の雑木林を歩くことにしました
皆さん 今から
森を歩いてるところを想像してください
雑木林を歩き出すと
始め５分ぐらいは
いろんなことが頭をよぎります
今日の仕事のこと
家族のこと
ご飯のこと
頭の中は散らかってます
それでも ゆっくり歩いてくと
木の隙間から光が差し込んでいて
目に映る木の幹や葉っぱの色や形が
全部違うことに気付きます
清々しくて
ちょっと冷たい空気が
鼻から入って喉を通り身体を満たします
足元では
「あ！どんぐり！」
手に取って「ヤッター！クヌギだ！」と
ポケットにしまいます
ザク ザク ザク
落ち葉を踏む音が
どんどん大きく聞こえてきて
頭の上の方では
チチチとかピーピーとか
鳥の鳴き声も聞こえてきます
カサカサカサカサ
横で音が聞こえた時には
手の届く範囲で
生き物の存在を感じて
怖くなって早歩きします
寒くなったら
ポケットに手を入れて
クヌギを触ってもいいし
木に抱きついたりもします
しばらく歩くと息が上がってきます
一旦止まって またゆっくり歩き出します
20分ほど五感に集中して山を歩いてると
始め 散らかってた頭の中が
自然と雲ひとつない青空のような
爽快感に包まれます
どうですか？
気持ち良さそうでしょう
それから僕は 山道を見つけては
五感を感じて歩くようにしています
そしたらうれしいことに
娘にも 仲間にも
「最近イライラしてないね」って
言われるようになったんです
落ち込んだ時にも
リセットできる時間になりましたし
自分にとって価値がないと思ってたこと
そういうことにも
興味が持てるようになったんです
不思議なことに
自分のパフォーマンスが上がってたんです
ここから僕が学んだのは
人間はバランスが大事ということです
生産的な活動も必要だけど
人間らしいムダも大事です
生産的な活動をするために
非生産的な行動も愛してあげてください
凹んだとき 落ち込んだ時には
自分の五感に集中して
山をゆっくり歩けば
爽快感に包まれて
周りの反応も変わります
ぜひ あなたにとっての森を見つけて
山歩きを楽しんでください
ありがとうございました
（拍手)